they have them for the prices in
behavioral economics
can you explain what it is behavioral
economics means that you take into
account human psychological factors such
as our limited rationality our social
concerns we care about the well-being of
others as well and also our lack of
self-control these are the three main
factors that are accounted for him in
the behavioral economics and what are
the main the major contributions from
this year's prize Loren he has worked in
all three areas and made groundbreaking
proposals and also a lot of experiments
in the areas that has shown the economic
consequences of these human factors you
can call that man so there is proposed
theories in all three areas for more
economical system is useful called the
rational almost no even even though
Richard Thaler is from Chicago he
doesn't belong to the Chicago School who
has been one of the main proponents for
Homo economicus but he has really wanted
to show that humans the fact the human
factors really has an influence on
economic decisions the earlier models
has thought of this shortcoming as being
kind of random deviations and and not
really if you are irrational you will
soon be thrown out of the market but he
shown that this is not true these there
are systematic deviations in human
behavior that needs to be explained that
need to be explained yes so do you have
any examples of those systemic beta
versions well one is this model of of
mental accounting I mean we tend to keep
our spendings in different boxes so to
speak and
for additional economic theory says that
it doesn't matter where you put your
money you should be able to move it
between these boxes but people don't I
mean they have savings accounts for for
vacation that have one count for us
buying a new car and so on and I don't
want to spend money from one account to
use in another to pay off your credit
card debt for instance so that's one
example this is experimental science he
yeah he has also done lots of
experiments in particular when it comes
to our judgments of fairness there is
together with the earlier laureate to
Daniel Kahneman he has done a series of
experiments in all involving several
games ultimatum game they take their
game so cone that showed that people
really care about the being fair to
others what there is well in in wage
wages for instance that people are not
willing to be unfair in wages they don't
like when a company raises the price of
a product if demand suddenly rises they
think that there is a fair price for a
product and even if the company could
sell the the product at the higher price
that I don't think they should so it's
not a fair price that's another area so
you're more fair than economists talk
about us tradition and economic systems
we all only think about our own
self-interest of course you can say that
our being fair being just to you is good
for me in the long run so some
economists say that this can be modeled
but failure has shown that there are
more concerns and it's more it's more
general than has been fought before and
he's provided experimental evidence for
that side and his colleague the
dimensions Daniel Kahneman
it's also a previous price laureth they
work together and he also wrote a book
about thinking fast or slow so what does
Richard Taylor say about that well yeah
their relation is it's very interesting
because failure worked with Kahneman in
the early 1980s and he was inspired by
coloman and first his prospect theory
when he developed to the theory mental
accounting for instance or the theory of
the endowment effect is not always
contributions but then he also developed
this planner do a model that is used to
explain how we are not so good at saving
for our future well-being and actually
Daniel Kahneman has then later taken up
this matter so when he talks about
Thinking Fast and thinking slow this is
an example of such a planner and doer
model immediately the first one is the
one who lives in the present and the
slow one is the one who lives for from
the for the long perspective so one can
say that Kahneman has been inspired by
failures martin models that there is a
given and a take between these two price
we have seen this thinking about people
like about delayed rewards it is not you
is it new for economists the
psychological factors are not new I mean
they are all well known I mean these
bounded rationality in the limited
self-control and so on the well-known
psychological what Thaler has done is to
put this into a economic context and
shown that it has large consequences for
economic decisions and he has also been
able to model some of these consequences
so it's not the psychological factors as
such but it's their impact on on
economic theory she also has coined a
new term
nudging can you explained it nudging
means that that you want to help people
to do something that I like themselves
and that's very important Taylor doesn't
want to be pretty paternalist he doesn't
want to impose rules on on people he
want to be a he wants to be a lately
terian paternalist that means that you
should always keep the freedom of the
individual but you can still device
certain mechanism to help the people
plan better for the future and his most
well-known examples of nudging on his
pension saving programs they save more
tomorrow why why is this you could you
could ask yourself if nudging is also a
kind of manipulation
that's the has been criticism against
his Nigeria but the criticism as often
missed this fact that a person can
always opt out of the program if he or
she wants to it's not there you're not
bouncing you can always leave a pension
saving program or you can always change
your mind concerning being an organ
donator or something like that so it's
it's a libertarian program and so it's
you're not imposing anything on process
in his nudging mechanism so in what way
would you say that I Taylor has changed
the economical science well the short
summaries that he's made economics more
human did you say when you called him
this morning
hey hey he was slow to wake up I must
say I think he was it was not prepared
for it it was happy of course yes yes he
was happy but he was quite taken by that
I was my impression
thank you very much